I have been taking the black sand capsules, that's the black sand bloodroot capsules.
And the immune, that is, this person's talking about the valovia immune product,
then you suggest it. After a few weeks my number still went out significantly. So this person's
tumor markers are climbing. So 299 from 244 last month normally is less than 25. Should I
keep taking these? I answered yes, of course, you're not going to see. Okay, there's nothing
sort of bonds and that is going to make a change in a growing cancer within a couple of weeks.
So we have to be realists when we're dealing with cancer, we're dealing with any disease, we're dealing
with dysbiosis when we're dealing with, you know, any disease process, not just a symptom like a
headache and we're going to take an aspirin, it's going to go away. This is a disease process that
has been going on for many times, most the time, quite some time. So when you're trying to make a change,
let's say you start the right, or you start a new supplement, or you start a new medication,
or you start chemotherapy to think that you're going to have drastic changes immediately.
Well, it does happen, and it has happened, you know, with chemotherapy, with the right, with
supplements, we can't say that that's abnormal. So, you know, we've got to give things time to work
and time to, to do their work on your body and get your body working. So I would say, yes, keep taking